so doctor strange two just came out on
disney plus what was that like yesterday
uh technically it's thursday so yeah
wednesday and i'm going back and
watching it and as i'm watching it i
started thinking i was like where did
wanda go at the end of doctor strange
too which by the way spoilers for a
movie that's been out for a few months
if you haven't seen it by now that's a u
problem not a me problem
so i was sitting there thinking i was
like where did she go at the end of it
right like we kind of we know how that
played out that she seemingly quote
unquote died but there's there was never
a body and so i don't know if it was
ever confirmed that she did die and so
my thought is where in the world
did she go and as these wheels started
turning as you guys know when it comes
to these theories that i have these just
different ideas coming to my head
and i started thinking about dark rain
now i know it's going to sound crazy
those guys who read the story of dark
rain i know you're going to be like no
there's no way it's dark rain i think
they're going to do that but with a
different they're going to do with a
twist it's going to be dark rain and
name only but not really the way that we
saw it right especially not siege on
asgard although that would be cool so
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with this it all goes back to civil war
right at the end of civil war
tony stark was made director of shield
that was his reward for basically being
a dick and so then in between dark rain
and civil war you got two events the
first one was house of m which most of
you guys know about that if for no other
reason than one division and all the
interest in scarlet witch as a result of
you know the one division show and all
that kind of stuff heightened levels of
power and whatnot
once house of m comes to an end you go
into secret invasion and secret invasion
was basically the story where it turned
out that scrolls were secretly replacing
superheroes across the world tony stark
was kicked out as director of shield
because the question was how could you
possibly be director of the world's
foremost intelligence agency and not
know this is happening now norman
osborne the green goblin intercepted
information at a crucial point in time
that allowed him to basically turn the
tide of the war and he was he
essentially replaced tony stark as the
director of shield dismantled it renamed
it to hammer and then did what villains
do now the thing about this is that
superhuman registration was still in
effect and so those superheroes who
stood against norman osborne which was
basically all of them uh they all just
went underground they couldn't publicly
stand against him and so in response to
this norman osborne ended up launching
the dark versions of superhero teams
dark avengers dark x-men different
things like that so my thought was this
the big villain of the new marvel
cinematic universe phase whatever you
want to call it is king the conqueror
right now i know this is going to sound
crazy what if wanda was plucked out
right what if she was snatched up by
king the conqueror now i know it's going
to sound kind of nuts but what if that's
happened right and and here's it's
entirely possible here's the reason why
imagine that happening right imagine
that whole situation unfolding
everything at the temple and all that
kind of stuff everything's crumbling
down they've all taken off juan is about
to die and then everything freezes stops
right there and kane the conqueror shows
up and kane the conqueror is like let's
have a discussion or he whisks her away
with kane the conqueror it's not really
stopping time so much as it is traveling
through time so he probably wouldn't be
able to stop things in that traditional
sense but he basically whisks her away
and it was and is essentially like
here's the deal i can give you what you
want i can give you the thing that
you're looking for right a reality where
you have your kids i know you kind of
changed your ways and you know you saw
the light and all that kind of stuff but
let's be honest with ourselves if you
really could go back to a universe where
your kids were there and you could live
that life would you live it right i
found a reality there's a reality that
exists out there where the wanda
maximoff in that universe had her kids
but she died and so now they don't have
a mother you don't have children i can
get you to that universe but i need you
to do something for me right imagine
that's the case because one of the
things that immortus told us right like
he remains what i'm going to call him
awards it's basically what he is one of
the things that mortis told us at the
end of loki is that his version of kane
the conqueror right like his alternate
version that king
is evil on a level that we haven't seen
before and it's not that far outside the
realm of possibility that he would just
show up to wanda promise her everything
in the world and then lie because what
can she do to him right he he literally
manipulates a time stream all he has to
do is go back in time and just adjust
things so that she and and quicksilver
never have their powers awakened using
the mind stone by baron von strucker and
wanda maximoff never exists in the
marvel cinematic universe as we know her
we've never seen or heard of her and the
entire timeline changes because of that
right that's literally all he has to do
or he can go back in time stop her from
being born or he can go back in time and
ensure that bomb detonates in the
apartment that she's in when it crashes
into the place where her and and uh and
quicksilver are and they never exist her
npatro never exists in the mcu right
there's a lot of things he could do to
just erase her history maybe he blocked
males or whatever the case is now the
question would be why
what would be the purpose when it comes
to this
right what's the purpose of doing this
whole thing my idea here
is what i think they're going to do with
came to conquer and i've been saying
this for a while and i think it rings
true because cain the conqueror his
story is about time which means the
movie that we deal with whatever that
final climactic film is that deals with
king conqueror is gonna deal with time
what i think we're gonna see is some
kind of avengers forever situation what
i think cain the conqueror is doing is i
think he's traveling through the time
stream and grabbing different avengers
from different points in time
and they're basically becoming his
avengers his dark avengers and that's it
right his own avengers team and then in
turn you basically get the other
versions right the light avengers if you
want to call them that right the good
guys and you end up having like an
avengers team from different points in
time this movie that we get with king
this final face this would be the way
that you get chris evans captain america
back and robert downey jr's iron man
back right it's the way that you get
some of these avengers that we all know
and love we get them like we bring them
back to the mcu possibly some avengers
that we haven't seen yet it'd be a great
way to do that right it'd be a great way
to segue into that i think that would be
awesome to kind of give us a sort of
past meets present now there is a
credible argument to make there no those
original avengers iron man captain
america all that kind of stuff they had
their time right they had 10 years now
we're on to the next thing let's just
focus on the next group of superheroes
that's entirely fair i i 100 agree with
that and i wouldn't see an issue with
that but when you're dealing with
someone like kang you're dealing with
the idea of time now the reason why i
think this sort of thing is possible is
because that's basically what happened
with the whole ultron right the ultron
forever sway line those you guys who
never saw that ultron forever was
basically a reworking of the original
avengers forever story except to focus
on ultron instead of it being avengers
that were effectively plucked out of
time facing you know from like different
eras you kind of got the same thing but
it was basically where ultron had
conquered the world and he had his own
like robotic avengers team right his own
kind of dark avengers to a degree i
could easily see them reworking that
with kane the conqueror and i'm gonna
tell you i think that would be cool i
think it'd be pretty awesome to have
that right i don't know if it'd be like
a dark version of steve rogers or
something along those lines we know they
borrow very heavily like the mcu borrows
very very heavily from jonathan hickman
and his run on avengers and new avengers
and i don't think it's outside the realm
of possibility for that because for
those of you guys who ever read that
story there is a point where in
alternate reality avengers team invades
like they show up in the main marvel
universe and instead of it being like
thor who can lift his hammer who like
you know whosoever holds this hammer if
they be worthy shall possess the power
of thor the idea is whosoever holds this
hammer if they be unworthy shall possess
the power of thor literally you have to
be a villain like a bad guy or like an
unworthy person who's not pure of heart
to lift that hammer so there's like
different evil versions of characters
from across the multiverse i think wanda
would be one of those big heavy hitters
right one of those people that just
catches the attention because well while
we've been shown different versions of
wanda across the multiverse and since we
only have a couple the one that she was
trying to possess the one that she had
dreams of the ones that she was looking
at it seems like wanda from 616 is the
only version of wanda that becomes that
corrupted goes that crazy and becomes
that powerful that they all have the
ability to use their use their powers or
whatever but she's the only one that
truly becomes the scarlet witch it seems
like she's the only one in the
multiverse that's like that and if
that's the case that makes her unique
right maybe like superior iron man we
end up getting him right the the only
version of iron man across the
multiverse that got all the infinity
stones for himself or maybe some version
of thanos or something along those lines
i think it'd be cool i think it'd be
pretty baller to see that happen so i
want to know what you guys think right
do you think this is a credible
possibility that wanda in doctor strange
was snatched up by kane the conqueror
because he is in effect forming his own
dark avengers team to combat whatever
forces he ends up going against and that
at the end of the day this movie is
effectively going to have
different evil avengers from across the
multiverse facing off against good guy
avengers from across the multiverse or
from the time stream both past and
present let me know what you guys think
i'm really curious because i think this
is a really
really legitimate possibility i mean i
really really do and if it's not i'd be
kind of disappointed because i feel like
this would just be a fantastic chance to
bring together past and present avengers
right i mean i think it would just be
cool like imagine what it would look
like when you have
chris evans captain america and robert
downey jr's iron man
meeting like
moon night and and teaming up with
i don't know like america chavez you
know or or something along those lines
right imagine that kind of team up
taking place or maybe they bring in adam
rasheer the blue marvel or we get
hyperion or something like that imagine
that were to happen like imagine we got
that whole thing i think it creates
incredible possibilities here i really
really do so with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end
again i really want to know what you
guys think about this idea i really want
to know what your opinions are and let
me know down in the comment section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace